good morning Hank it's Wednesday June
4th the day after Barack Obama secured
the nomination for the Democratic Party
for president but there's a burning
question with whom shall he run god I've
got good grammar hey this is my favorite
time of the every four years these heady
weeks in between when we have a nominee
and when we have a running mate because
right now
anybody could be our next vice president
I mean except for the 54 percent of the
American population who's under the age
of 35 and anyone who's more than one of
the following non-white non-christian
non-male or indicted for a felony it's
like basically the pool of candidates is
like the 20% of Americans who are either
old white guys or old white women and
Condoleezza Rice but Hank we're not here
to talk about Republicans instead I'd
like to introduce you to ten of the most
likely running mates for Barack Obama in
2008 number one the junior senator from
New York Hillary Clinton the up side 18
million people have voted for this year
and she's hugely popular with the kind
of voters that Barack Obama has had
trouble winning over and she has the
highest favorability ratings of any
potential VP candidate but she also has
the highest unfavorability ratings also
to be frank she and Obama have less
chemistry than Diane Keaton and John
Cusack and must love dogs
number two Montana Governor Brian
Schweitzer choice is funny and
personable and he's got that kind of
down-home thing that plays so well in
Appalachia plus he's a really popular
governor in a red state but he wears a
lot of bolo ties and I gotta say I'm not
sure the American people are ready to be
one heartbeat away from a below tide
presidency number three Delaware Senator
Joe Biden up side he's got the best
grass before in policy in the Senate
plus he knows the difference between
Sunnis and Shias which is more than can
be said for certain Republican nominees
but there's just something kind of Joe
Biden II about him you know you look at
him and you just think like oh man
you're so Joe Biden II number four
Connecticut Senator Chris Dodd the
upside I have absolutely no idea I mean
everyone says that this guy is a
first-tier vice presidential candidate
but I don't get it I mean yes he used to
date Princess Leia and that's hot but
that was 20 years ago now he's married
to some woman it wasn't in any of the
Star Wars movies I don't understand why
we would vote for this guy
number 5 Kansas governor Kathleen
Sebelius up side she's a brilliant red
state governor and she knows how to get
things done in a bite
artisan way but it's not clear how good
she is at campaigning also an Obama
Sebelius ticket just doesn't trip off
the tongue I mean Obama might as well
pick as his running mate the girl who
sells seashells by the seashore six
Virginia governor Tim Kaine the upside
he could help turn Virginia blue in oe+
he's a super religious Catholic and
Obama has had trouble attracting
Catholics oh that could work out nicely
but I find him kind of boring also he
kind of has the Jack Nicholson playing
the joker eyebrows thing happening
number seven seven finger junior senator
from Montana Jon Tester the upside he
only has 7 fingers because of a farming
accident that kind of thing plays
fantastic in Appalachia plus he's funny
as hell and he's gotten the same $6
flattop haircut at the same place in
Montana's whole life I've always said
that the worse the haircut the better
the man but he has almost no political
experience but who cares you can buy
political experience you can't buy seven
fingers number eight the junior senator
from Virginia Jim Webb former Republican
former Secretary of the Navy big
military guy plus he writes novels and
they're actually really good but he has
a reputation for misogyny and all ten
fingers number nine Republican senator
from Nebraska Chuck Hagel he's a
moderate Republican opposed to the war a
man of his convictions plus he's a
Vietnam veteran and he's from the West
and he's super Catholic Chuck Hagel you
are political demographers wet dream but
you are also opposed to stem-cell
research which isn't gonna fly with a
lot of Democrats and finally number 10
New Mexico Governor Bill Richardson a
popular governor and a state Obama needs
to win plus he speaks Spanish but the
media is always saying it's not clear
whether or not he's been thoroughly
vetted which in this case is code for
everybody knows he cheats on his wife so
Hank that's a brief introduction to some
of the people we could be seeing a lot
of in the next few months
hey nerdfighters led us and potentially
Barack if he happens to be reading the
comments on our YouTube channel know who
you think should be vice-president and
Hank I believe I'll see you tomorrow